I carry your heart Wiggly I carry it in
my heart I am never without it anywhere
I go you go my dear
and whatever is done by only me is your
doing my darling I fear no fate for you
are my fate my sweet
I want no world or beautiful you are my
world my true and it's you are whatever
a moon has always meant and whatever a
Sun will always sing is you here is the
deepest secret nobody knows here is the
root of the root and the bud of the bud
and the sky of the sky the tree called
life which grows higher than soul can
hope or mind can hide and this is the
wonder it's keeping the stars apart I
carry your heart I carry it in my heart
of all the many highly experimental
poems by EE Cummings I carry your heart
with me I carry it in is among the most
straightforward and approachable it's
the one you're most likely to hear at
weddings or at weddings in rom-coms I
carry your heart with me I carry it in
my heart and because this poem seems
effortless it feels pulled out of time -
I think that was what Cummings wanted to
make this poem universal a
quintessential love poem for the modern
age I mean just take a look at the five
concrete images that he uses hearts moon
Sun
three stars it's hard to imagine five
symbols more archetypal so the intention
here is clearly universal appeal but
that's not a slight on the poems
construction or its meaning just the
opposite in fact as Yeats once
brilliantly wrote about his own craft a
line will take us hours maybe yet if it
does not seem a moment's thought our
stitching and unstitching has been not
so first let's take a look at the formal
construction of I carry your heart the
first thing to notice is that the poem
is split into two overlapping parts
everything that's outside the
parentheses and everything that's inside
them this follows the theme set up in
the first line the theme of the
narrator's lover being contained within
his heart and vice versa this reciprocal
relationship is hammered home in the
first stanza with anywhere I go you go
and whatever is done by only me is your
doing every statement in this poem is
followed by a parenthetical statement
and frequently key words used outside of
them are found inside as well linking
the two parts and the two people
parentheses are the perfect punctuation
to use because visually they actually
represent the image of containment as
critic Roy Tartakovsky has observed
Cummings find several poetic functions
from the parentheses throughout his work
whether it's to convey intimacy or
protection or to give a direct address
to the subject or like we just discuss
to use its crescent shape as an icon in
itself the neatest Tartakovsky notes
parentheses have a somewhat
contradictory place in all our writing
formally they're supposed to contain
throwaway information stuff that would
theoretically be perfectly okay to leave
out but because of this because they
don't have to be there and yet still are
parenthetical comments call attention to
themselves for grounding their contents
while back rounding them at the same
time ambiguity like that is exactly what
cummings loves to play with and it
reinforces the poems themes clearly
cummings is using the parentheticals for
in two
see you can see that in his editions of
my dear my darling my sweet my true but
he also uses them to develop his
philosophy of self and love Seaver
Cummings love is a condition in which
two fragmented selves come together to
form a more perfect unity and if there's
one great theme in his collected work
it's the importance of being a truly
transcendentally alive individual
against the dulling and alienating
forces of modern progress but the
individual self was always a problematic
idea for Cummings whereas sometimes he
avowed that man is a miraculously whole
human being elsewhere like in the same
sentence he says that man's only
happiness is to transcend himself again
and again his poetry of firms that
transcendence comes with losing the self
in love whether it said gracefully
outright like when he writes losing
through you what seemed myself I find
selves unimaginably mine or it's
demonstrated in some formal fireworks
like in this poem where the you and me
is literally fused together and the
speaker has difficulty determining what
form of the verb is best to use love's
ability to transcend is the focus of I
carry your heart and cummings is using
whatever he can to explore different
connotations of transcendence just take
a look at the third stanza love is
literally a cosmic force that holds the
stars in the firmament but it's also the
deepest secret and cuming suggests this
deepness by nesting the secret in
parentheses which are themselves nested
into the poem and the secret is buried
further in the root of the root in the
bud of the bud and the symbols I
mentioned earlier son and particularly
moon are symbols of transcendence
throughout his poetry I mean what has
the moon always meant to Cummings in a
great essay by Cummings critic Martin
Hooser which I'll link to below the moon
significance is traced across several
poems it's variously described as a
remarkable splinter a dainty
mademoiselle watch spring a balloon a
big red dog mystery
small hands and as the shyest metaphor
the cummings has a transcendental
reverence for the moon but he has a hard
time pinning it down in language that's
why it's the shyest metaphor many
attempt to understand it to know it will
result in the symbol fleeing further
away this is what the moon has always
meant to cummings and it's the way he
feels about love and poetry too in his
notes which are collected at harvard he
once wrote to know is to possess and any
fact is possessed by everyone who knows
it whereas those who feel the truth are
possessed not possessors like the great
american transcendentalist cummings
believes truth and poetry and love
cannot be comprehended only experienced
with his poetry and all its intense
experimentation he attempts to
short-circuit our impulse toward knowing
so that we might experience language
anew I carry your heart is a rare
attempt at clarity in form and content
it points toward love just as it points
toward Cummings philosophy but it's true
magic is in the way it unfolds
effortlessly in a rhythm and cadence
harmonious with feeling
hey everybody thanks for watching I want
to point you guys in the direction of a
channel that I really love wisecrack
we've been pushing back and forth to
each other because I think if you like
my stuff you're definitely going to love
what they do they do
8-bit philosophy thug notes but I really
been loving earthling cinema which is
like film analysis from the perspective
of a Crabby but hilarious earthling from
the future I'm a sucker for high-concept
stuff and it's really smart anyway go to
their channel watch this one that they
just did on Mad Max which is really good
and subscribe and tell them the nerd
writer sent you in comments yeah they're
just good people anyway if you want to
pledge to the nerd writer directly you
can click right here go to my patreon I
just started a blog on patreon so if you
pledge dollar per video you can get
access to that some behind the scenes
stuff that's cool anyway I'll see you
guys next Wednesday